6 26 on your friday morning how about
cleaning up and moving on where the 95
meets the 215 northern beltway come on
along we're going
centennial bowling
there we go this week's report nothing
like last week when we talked about oso
blanca being shut down for three years
for now we're just talking about a
temporary off-ramp closure
ndot crew is going to be cleaning up
getting ready for more work we're
talking about the ramp from the north 95
that gets you off at buffalo
it has been closed the past couple of
nights are keeping it open through the
weekend then shutting it down again
sunday night so from eight o'clock each
evening till five
each morning through thursday the 18th
just follow the detour signs you should
be able to get where you're going with
maybe some minimal delays
also you don't have to be a junior
traffic buddy or even a traffic nerd to
enjoy
the nevada department of
transportation's website that is all
about
all the work that's been going on in the
area as well as the work yet to be done
it really does help you out we got the
link on our website
eightnewsnow.com you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully
please put down that phone if there's
something driving you crazy email me
traffic8newsnow.com